After years of waiting, "The Batman" has finally
swooped into theaters.
It's been a long road for this new version
of the Dark Knight to make its way to the
big screen, as the production was hit with
pandemic-related delays and setbacks.
Robert Pattinson himself reportedly caught
COVID-19 during filming, so it's a minor miracle
that Warner Bros. has finally been able to
release the Matt Reeves-directed movie.
Thankfully, the film pushes its cast of DC
heroes and villains in new directions, many
of which should even surprise longtime fans.
The action kicks off in Bruce Wayne's second
year of crime fighting, so audiences don't
have to sit through yet another origin story.
When a sadistic individual called the Riddler
starts targeting the corrupt officials of
Gotham, Batman sets out to stop his violent
war before the villain can hurt the rest of
the city.
The Caped Crusader also crosses paths with
some other iconic characters from the Batman
mythos, as he gets help from Lt. James Gordon
and Catwoman aka Selina Kyle.
He even goes up against two other iconic Bat-villains
— Penguin and Carmine Falcone — who are
at the heart of organized crime in Gotham.
That said, there's never any doubt who the
big bad of this film is.
When it comes to the film's cryptic serial
killer, director Matt Reeves and co-writer
Peter Craig take a new approach to the riddle-obsessed
villain.
Before we go any further, be warned: Spoilers
ahead!
Let's get the most obvious change out of the
way first: the Riddler's new duds.
Gone are the days of bright green spandex
with question marks painted all over — no,
this version of the villain takes a more tactical
approach to his look.
He sports a dark green military jacket with
a similarly colored hoodie underneath.
Then there's his incredibly creepy mask that
he wears with transparent glasses over the
top to mask his real identity — which we'll
get to later on.
After the first teaser for the film arrived
back in August 2020, comics writer Nick Derington
took to Twitter to point out that Riddler's
headgear is actually an Extreme Cold Weather
Mask used by the U.S. military.
So why does Riddler take a DIY approach to
his terrifying look?
Well, for starters he doesn't have the same
funds as Bruce Wayne to create a high-tech
suit — so he probably shops in army surplus
stores for his gear.
Let's not forget that this version of the
villain is much more of a homegrown terrorist
than Jim Carrey's gleeful mischief-maker in
"Batman Forever."
He's also a huge departure from the sharp-suited
version of the character in the "Gotham" TV
series.
The small screen's Riddler is also a former
GCPD forensic scientist.
Although he clearly enjoys taunting Gotham
in his livestreams — a flamboyant, eccentric
Riddler wouldn't fit into this universe that
Matt Reeves is building.
The Riddler also tells the hero that his mask
allows him to become his true self.
It's all an attempt to bond with Batman, as
he points out that the Caped Crusader's persona
is also his true face.
It's the classic "we're the same, you and
I" approach to connecting the hero and the
villain.
There's another surprising difference in the
Riddler's character from what DC fans might
expect: His name isn't Edward Nigma.
This time around the villain uses his birth
name, Edward Nashton, a choice that's mainly
about making sure these characters feel natural
to the world of "The Batman."
The “E.Nigma” joke wouldn't work as well
here.
It just feels kinda silly.
Sure, Nashton's job as an accountant is the
reason behind his war on corruption in the
first place, but the Riddler persona is who
he really is.
Plus, he's already projecting majorly enigmatic
vibes even without the pseudonym.
When the police eventually manage to arrest
the Riddler, his wallet is filled with a couple
of ID cards — so they're not 100% sure who
he actually is.
Riddler's detached personality, his unhinged
crimes, and his bizarre costume even call
back to a real-life serial killer.
When speaking to MovieMaker, Reeves said,
"The premise of the movie is that the Riddler
is kind of molded in an almost Zodiac Killer
sort of mode."
It's easy to see the connection, since the
Riddler sends messages written in code, much
like the Zodiac Killer who terrified San Francisco
in the 1970s.
Thankfully, Alfred Pennyworth happens to be
a master code-breaker, which is hugely helpful
when he and Bruce are picking apart Riddler's
cryptic messages.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
DC movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.